This motorcycle is built for the global market.
It's lightweight, it's agile...
...and it's able to meet homologation and emissions requirements in all local areas.
The G 310 R is made to be versatile.
Despite the aggressive styling, this motorcycle maintains a natural riding position.
This gives a really relaxed riding experience.
The balanced position of the handlebars and the footrests...
...allow the rider excellent control of the bike.
As standard, the G 310 R has a low seat height of 785 millimeters.
This makes it easy to manage for riders of all statures.
As with any BMW, the switchgear is well laid out and easy to use...
...whether you got big hands or small hands.
The lightweight and stiff steel trellis frame forms the backbone of the G 310 R.
It gives excellent stability and steering response.
Balancing compact design with comfortable full-size ergonomics,...
...the G 310 R opens up a whole new world of riding experience in its segment.